my next guest is a pure delight and i
would say that even if she wasn't
sitting to my right wearing very bright
clothing studio 666 or 666 will be
available in theaters nationwide on
february 25th her touch me tour for more
information on dates to buy tickets to
go see her whitney cummings dot com
slash tour good to see you whitney
cummings hi i know i'm dressing crazy i
just i don't care anymore i love it all
my friends are dying i've only been
wearing glasses
i've only been wearing black for the
past two weeks going to funerals so i
figured i'd brainstorm that's where i
saw you last last time i saw you and i
totally said
at bob saggett's funeral where i was
completely lost because
you know we're both we were tight with
saggit like he would want us making
crazy jokes and it was just it was so
weirdly serious and
all i could think about was the story
that bob told me uh once we were in new
york where it's because bob's got like
you know there's like five
things in your brain they're like this
is the funny the hardest i've ever
laughed he's got like two or three of my
five one time we were in new york and
you know his sister had a horrible
disease called scleroderma
which you know deteriorates her skin and
we were in new york one time and you
know he would do the charity event every
year we do stand up at it and uh i had
ordered lasagna at the barrie hotel and
as i was eating it he goes hey stop
eating my sister
oh my gosh
it was like the heart it was one of
those laughs where you like have to like
go for a walk to like collect yourself
like one of those like healing old
wounds laughs
and he was unbelievable it would be that
brutal but then he also would like to be
so dumb like i remember one time we were
at some restaurant in hollywood and
you know when you're like done with
eating like everyone just gets on their
phone automatically you know
and i look over and bob had ordered like
a sunday or something like some dumb
like fruit sundae and uh i look over and
like he's typing on an actual blackberry
like the berry
and it's like
and i was like what are you doing and he
had been doing it for like two minutes
like he was waiting for us to notice
that it was all like mushed up in his
hands so i was like what are you doing
he's like i'm typing on my blackberry
and it was like so dumb the commitment
the commitment to it the fact that he
was just waiting for us to notice and it
was like all bleeding all over his hands
but but i really feel like the the
speeches were also so
right you know i feel like when you go
to the funeral for something that you
love so much and the speeches suck
you're like you're bombing like you're
ruining yeah they were great like thank
god you know they killed at the funeral
oh my god totally because like i was
like this we can't bomb this funeral for
bob and um it was so funny that his wife
was like yeah bob still doesn't know
what i do for a living
and then his daughter the funniest thing
his daughter one of his daughters was
saying like how him and how her and bob
had gone public and
he would like point to random people and
be like aren't you glad that weirdo's
not your dad
like what if he was your dad like are
you glad you got me like you're such a
weirdo it sounded exactly what he what
he would be like and you know he was
here just a few you know months ago and
um you know
it's also just being a comedian at a
funeral like seeing you really grounded
me because
how did i cry well because our instincts
are like to just like say something
inappropriate and like disgrace the
occasion and just you know like you know
it happened in florida a couple days
before and nicki glaser and i we walked
up to the coffin you know and i don't
think we
you know you don't realize it doesn't
really hit you it still maybe hasn't hit
me frankly but we walked up to the
coffin and put our hands on it and i
just whispered to her
there's no way bob's in here
like there's no way florida people got
him here in three days right
like he's not in here right you
appreciated that though yeah we were
just kind of like the only thing we can
do right now is just pretend like they
didn't get him here and there's just a
body supply chain somehow
okay in the orlando people got him here
in three days my luggage is still in
orlando from two months ago like i just
feel like he's not in here
and that's okay like we were just you
know it was it was like the perfect mix
i feel like of incredibly reverent but
also
like
there was a there was a warmth that was
inspiring because he because because bob
saget i got whitney cummings here on the
rich island show and i think bob would
love the fact that we're talking about
him here yeah is that he he was the fact
is that he was so nice to so many people
and he really cared when he asked you
about your family and he really cared
and he really was just into that like he
was he he geeked out on love and family
and then would say the most
inappropriate stuff
right on top of it like he when he was
here he was talking about you know you
know he he was talking about uh um i
asked him about reckless and he started
telling a story about reckless but he
mentioned his father once he goes you
remember my dad right and i
answered
seriously like yeah i remember your
father and it was just to set up from
saying he remembers you had nice soft
hands for him yes
and i'm like wait a minute so i wasn't
supposed to seriously answer that
question i should just let you be the
comedian like that literally is what
happened he's like i'll get this yeah
it's just i it also was so like normally
when i go to a funeral and like you know
you know because when you're in pain and
grieving you just you're mad at everyone
and need someone to blame you know you
need to distract yourself from the grief
by being like why did that person wear
this to the funeral like why is this
horror in a you know
a black miniskirt like like you know
you're just whatever you hate everyone
because but it was like
i i i this is how great bob is because
well you know that as soon as someone
dies everyone's their best friend like
all of a sudden they like are going
through their photos looking for the
dead person they had a selfie with like
i'm like how did you like you found out
that person was dead and instantly just
went to your iphone and started looking
at the selfie of youtube together to
pretend you were best friends like you
know but everyone at that funeral was
like
bo was bob's best friend and i it didn't
even make me competitive i was like yeah
he is the kind of person that like
everyone he was everyone's best friend
within two minutes when you said [ __ ]
in a mini skirt i'm like how dare you
talk about norman lee your life
we went together she was cracking me up
because a lot of people were carrying
the coffin like comedians
we are so out of shape like watching all
those comedians struggle with that
coffin was embarrassing nikki was like
can we get the dave chappelle from five
years ago
i feel like we're not gonna get i feel
like we're not gonna get this casket in
the ground yeah this is bad whitney
cummings here on the rich eyes and show
so is uh you mentioning your grief is
that why you're watching a lot of
football you know what i've been
watching a lot of football i almost went
to the rams game the other day i'm only
here to bully you for super bowl tickets
so i do you think i need to do the show
anymore i mean how many times do i come
here i don't know anything about sports
no but what i do want to know is that
i'm touring and uh everyone's worried
about getting canceled like comedians
are all like canceled if you say
anything you know
i'm only worried about getting cancelled
by cities in states because they don't
they won't they don't forget one time i
was in boston and i was at the wilbur
theater and i was talking about i was
doing a joke about how like every guy
when they watch sports they um they wear
a jersey like as if they're on the team
like you have to like i don't wear like
i don't watch grey's anatomy and scrubs
like i don't know why you need to wear
like you're not getting drafted like
there's like when someone gets hurt
they're not going to call up and be like
hey
chris we need you buddy are you in yeah
hold on a second i'm in the 300 level i
can make it down there all day i'll be
right back every guy has a football in
the back of their car even at 45 like
just in case
like we're out of footballs man can you
grab that one from your truck the golf
clubs are literally in my truck
and so
and so um
basically i was like telling starbucks i
was like yeah like i said the boston
patriots
well they used to be called that though
right yeah like technically back in like
the the kennedy administration way back
yeah okay i know i look like joan
reverse but i'm not that old um i ha it
took me like 30 minutes to get the crowd
back
it was bad it was like
like it really but i've dated a couple
boston fans one of whom
when uh or no i was dating a boston fan
that when they were playing i think it
was when they got in the super bowl
every time you're the most suspicious
fan it's don't you think like the
superstitious what do you call it
superstitious and suspicious of other
teams probably two and women and women
i mean my god so every time they would
win for some reason i would come in
halfway through the game and like sit on
the edge of the couch oh boy like
because i'd only go in if they were
winning because we would break up every
time they lose so that was a lot of
times and so uh i would sit on the edge
of the couch and they'd win
we break up the next year
football season starts and he's like can
you come sit on the couch
dude we haven't spoken in a year
can we can we mark the just ending
career of tom brady with with how how
often you were on this couch and now
you're like because he won six super
bowls there were you do you feel like
he's gonna be remembered as like like
john mcenroe level like just the guy who
had a tantrum through his computer no
here's what we're gonna remember him
before are you sure
i feel like i feel like you need another
year to get that out of our head here's
what we were wondering about tom brady
is what's the number of pounds he's
going to gain in his first year out oh
god how's this going to go what's he
going to do i don't that's the question
because normally football players when
they're done playing they j they just
get huge they're like screw it yeah yeah
yeah yeah done i'm done trying i hope we
get some pics some old tweets resurfaced
i want to go full disgrace there's no
way someone can stay a hero anymore
there's no way he's not going to drive a
golf cart into a school bus like there's
no way
who has successfully cell's going to
smash the back windshield
that's a different florida successfully
stayed like dignified you know i feel
like a weird pic is coming out i feel
like
wearing fishnets
of chipotle is about to surface i don't
know what it's going to be
what's he going to do with this i think
that is his biggest scandal is that he
would be eating off of his diet like
that would be for him the clothing brand
so he still has to be kind of a model
that's embarrassing he's going to be on
the math dancer in 20 minutes this is
gonna go so south so fast my children
would lose their freaking little minds
if tom brady showed up on the masked
dancer or masked singer he's gonna
humiliate himself somehow they think
they think every single person in the
history of the mass singer is the most
famous person of all time i did the
masked dancer and how'd that work out i
was on the t at the time on uh
antibiotics and then had long covid and
i didn't know it was a children's show
and i was sexually harassing brian
austin green the entire time to where
they had to stop the show and they were
like there's like children in the
audience if you have to stop asking
brian austin green to like
it's like you have to stop
is and i was like oh i didn't realize i
didn't yeah yeah like our demo was
eight-year-olds right and yeah so you
had to
turn it down like we're disney can you
stop like it's already you already are
only here because like nine people
couldn't make it we're only here because
all the men who wanted to hire got
cancelled for sexual assault my parents
i mean sorry
me being the parent my kids think that
um
every single masked singer is either
barack obama okay lebron
so i've told them i have told them if
anybody's ever been revealed on the show
if they're ever beyonce or any member of
the obama family anymore it's more like
george foreman
like carrot top
it puts you in a difficult bind when
tommy chong is unmasked and your kids
say what's he famous for
killing daddy's brain
cells in the 90s
making daddy stupider cannot wait for
you to see up and smoke one day but
today's not that day
i remember there was a what have you
done a row you've been on a bunch of
roasts because we were on one together
right
tisch we did the steve tisch roast one
night which was just an absolute delight
and i have uh
jeff ross invites me to every single one
of them right uh for comedy central and
i'll attend as many as possible that's
crazy you were you were at the sag did
you decide
yes i was a writer on the saga roast and
that was the infamous roast when nor
macdonald also dad went up uh i'm really
sort of like
it's
it's just
i feel like it's just coming so hard
with comedians and legends you know um
and then with louis anderson happening
dan mintz had a hilarious joke he was
like um
meatloaf died of covid and louis
anderson died of meatloaf
sort of deal with grief but um yeah i
mean that's what jeff ross was saying
that saggett died to knock betty white
off the pages and he used a very awful
inappropriate word to describe betty
white that nobody ever uses but yeah but
i mean it's it's kind of like just it's
been a while time and i went to the
party afterwards and uh and we were just
sitting in the back just the only way we
could get through it is to be haters we
were like which comedian is gonna ruin
this by being a malignant narcissist and
making it about them
and um
who won
you can guess
i'll stay out of it
oh gosh this is now it's you've got to
guess the malignant narcissist yeah by
the way if they just mask it that could
be a show on fox yeah
masked malignant narcissism mask
narcissism
right now i would watch that let's pitch
it honestly i've got a lot of contacts
in this coming in september
tell me about this film um with food
firefighters are doing a horror comedy
movie and it's like sort of just like a
you know we're at a time where every
movie now is like trying to tell you how
to vote or lecture you on like morality
or like it's just
i don't know when there's a comedian i
signed up to just be a scumbag like i
don't want to have to be your hero
and be moral your moral compass you know
so i uh i just whenever a project comes
along that's just like this is all just
like
you know uh
just completely for entertainment and
entertainment alone i was reading the
script and i said no actually initially
because there was a scene where i had to
sing a heart song in front of
the entire band like i played dave i
play like the like the neighbor encino
[ __ ] straight offer um like a groupie
that is obsessed with just sleeping with
all of them and trying to get on their
bands so i'm like go up to them and i'm
like do you need a backup singer like
like and i start singing a heart song in
front of them
and then the day of they were like oh
turns out we can't get the license the
song and time so we're just gonna have
you sing everlong
by the foo fighters and i was like um
you want me to sing a foo fighter song
in front of all the fool fighters like i
it was
because also it's like me they're like
oh and he's gonna be bad at singing it's
gonna be so funny it's not funny it's
like it's like sad like people like feel
sorry for me it's like it's it's not
funny it's like is she okay
like and so i'm singing a foo fighter
song like looking at pat's smear in the
eyes and being like this is my actual
nightmare like singing
you know is this the horror to my hair
yeah
i get murdered in a very satisfying way
for all of you reddit people that hate
me you're gonna love me getting
murdered in this movie um and i got to
have some sex scenes with a foo fighter
so
hey that is what's called a bucket list
for some yeah and i had like a lot of
sutter home before it so it i looked
convincing studio 666 available in
theaters nationwide um you are in will
fortes in it too yeah it's like crazy
cast and dave girl like gets possessed
and murders all the band mates it's it's
like amazing i mean if dave grohl asks
you to do something the answer is of
course show up yeah it's the best and
he's
so funny and i don't understand why okay
i'm like is this a scientology thing why
are you so funny and so nice and so
talented this is fishy he's not a
scientologist no i don't think so but
it's just like suspicious when someone's
like good at everything and cool they're
like wait a minute yeah it can't be real
it can't be real yeah and then touch me
tool and sexually harass me it was very
insulting
touch me tour yes i'm touring all around
the country and um just trying to not
screw up the team names because i'm
going to lots of like random cities
because you know i definitely booked 60
cities assuming like half would cancel
because of it
and none of them canceled and i'm like
oh god i have to do these uh but yeah so
i'm doing like you know three four
cities a week and trying to get back out
there and you know do comedy and people
are ready to the people it's so it's so
done like comedians are such brats we're
such babies we're like no one listens
saying anything that i have to do comedy
for people in masks it's like like we'll
complain about sugar cookies and hot
pockets like they're just ignore us
ignore whatever you want to complain on
a hot pocket like remember well jim
gaffigan had a whole thing about hot
pockets right i think
yeah like will will gary goldman we
complain about sugar cookies like
there's nothing we will not blow out of
proportions i mean chris knows he's
married to one well that's the way it
goes that's right
are you married to one no not okay i
just want to make sure okay yeah no it's
not yeah i just need to know where the
register child and own a house right
yeah you're yeah this is the one thing
you can hold on to
one thing you're going to hold out on
where do i get that outfit um uh a
garbage can near you
outside carrot show it's like it's like
raggedy it's like raggedy i think you
get it at the aids quilt outlet i don't
know what is this
such a thing existed is that a good
fantasy team name
you know weed is now legal in california
and
youtube stars are designing merch and
this is what happens so i think we need
to make it illegal again are you gonna
fight jake paul next you know what i
might
i would i would never really spend a lot
of money on a fight but i would i could
win emotionally physically i don't know
i just i mean how would you emotionally
win over jake i'm just that's
manipulating men is my
daytona are you watching cheer are you
guys into cheerleading uh like are you
not allowed to watch that what do you
mean like like per like professional
cheerleading rivero it's this awesome
are any of your daughters in cheer no no
it's like it's my new favorite sport is
cheerleading uh
what's the sport in it it's what's that
what's the sport well it's it's like
it's gymnastics and it's okay okay all
right is this a show not everyone's just
worried about getting canceled they're
like we don't watch girls in tiny things
excuse me not at all
i thought cheerleaders i thought it was
like a sexual thing but like these girls
are like hardcore gymnasts and they're
like doing crazy stuff i totally get
that but i did not know that it was like
televised
no one knows cheer is it a scripted show
or just said no it's an unscripted show
about the best cheerleading team uh in
the country the best and it's made by
the guys that did lance last chance you
know
okay so it's really cool it's like
that's my new thing i did not just fart
this is why do you put guests into
leather
know
i did hear that i thought it's there an
earthquake or something this is crazy so
the only the only cheerleader stuff i
know is what yellow jacket now right
isn't that oh yellow jackets the show
soccer oh that's soccer all right i
thought they were cheerleader i didn't
know
yeah that's like i'm slowly getting into
it but i feel like those cheerleaders
should go into the nfl don't you think
or does nfl just want kind of
like i don't know i i don't think that
when the cheerleaders and gymnast and in
the nfl are known for their gymnastics
no i mean they're barely
in college they're you know that's
serious business psychology they got
pyramids and they flip them in the air
and stuff
nfl they just get him out of rehab and
just for the day i don't know about that
i don't know about that
that i'm unaware of i don't know if
we're allowed to just give him some
adderall and sort of see what happens
my god what are you watching on
television
i'm telling you i feel like football
would be even more fun if they got the
naverro cheerleaders to be like why
don't they have professional
cheerleaders like flying around in
between flying around in between
wouldn't that be cool that would be
great that would be great let's start
let's start super bowl 56.
instead you have these like sloppy trick
talk stars on the side studio 666
available in theaters nationwide on
february 25th
whitneycummings.com tour to see whitney
on tour the touch me to work good to see
you touch me tour yeah and thanks um it
was just so good to see you at that
funeral and i was like i just want to
come on and say hi guys i feel like i
always come on here and bomb but i just
you're asking i think you're the first
guest in our now eight years of this
show that's come on because i saw you at
a funeral
and i think i think and i think bob
saget
may he rest in peace and we look up and
see him i think he would be very pleased
awesome i agree and i think that
he would you know be so um honored that
all of his friends love each other so
much and and he he's i mean this is what
had to happen for uh people to talk
about him on on television
he's getting more press than ever i know
good to see you you too i love you all
right back at you at whitney cummings on
twitter and instagram right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here